You know, hey, Will, good morning. How are you today? Oh, hey, Sean. Yeah, good morning. I'm good, too. I set my thermostat, even though it's winter. Oh, my God, hang on. Fucking, let me sit down for this. Okay, go ahead.
I set my thermostat to put the air conditioning on because everybody in my building in New York has the heat on. So at night, I'm sleep with the air conditioning on. Isn't that kind of dumb? No, it's not dumb. I'm just trying to think of a synonym right now. Oh, you know what? It's Smartless.
Oh. Welcome to Smartless. So, Sean, Hey. Yeah, you know, now... I just, I'm just happy to be here. Shut up. Incredible.
This is amazing. Jason, don't talk to him like that. Hang on. Sean, shut up. Yeah. Sean, you're on Eastern Time, so he's more cups of coffee into his day than we are. Sean, he's so, he's such a... He never lets it show.
He works his freaking tail off. He's there in rehearsal doing this play. And then he just, shows up and he doesn't complain. Do you ever know that? Well, live with me. Let me ask Crankerville. Crankerville, do you notice?
I've never heard you complain about anything. He doesn't, right? I do. I kind of do. Well, I would... Like, it's Scottie's like, all he does is complain. Scotty's listening in that was this. So wait, so wait, is Scotty always on, always on an extra set of kids?
Not always, but a lot of times he listens, like, just for fun. I love it. Yeah. Now, Sean, you haven't, I got a full night of Willie's new look last night. Oh, right, yeah, yeah. He just looks so goddamn handsome with this facial hair. Look at that. Cut his hair.
Yeah, you never grow your beard out. I know, thank you. Yeah. Wear your rings, Willie. Did you get to keep the reins? I know, I know. So for Tracy, Will's doing this big film to follow up the other film. It's for a part?
It's not for a part? Yeah. Yeah, it's for the thing I just did with Tony Gilroy. Well, say what it is. Tony Gilroy's directing. You and Pedro Pascal, and who else? And Olivia Wilde and a lot of great people. And it's, yeah, it's called Bohemoth.
And, yeah. Yeah, it's very cool that you're part of that. Yeah, it was really fun. Yeah, it was really fun that they asked me to... Well, wait, are you playing some fucking stud? Because he's a... He's a... He's a...
I can't really say anything, because I realize that they haven't said anything of what it's about, So I'm not allowed to really say. It's not Star Wars. Fucking hit cake. Please, my dad. You have like watermark scripts and stuff? Of course.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, it's... Well, you're handsome in it. I can tell you that. So you're going to hold the look, you're going to keep the look. I mean, you know, listen, I mean, for anyone who cares out there, us soft actor guys, the only time we ever stumble into a new look, it's because somebody with taste in a makeup trailer kind of carved one into us,
for a part and then we're like, we're done with the movie and we're like, oh, maybe I'll just hold on to a little element of this. Look at me. Like when you had your long hair for a while. Well, I still, yeah, I mean, I still, Amanda, I came home, Amanda was like, oh, you're keeping that. Really? Oh, God.
Yeah. Yeah, but you cut it off pretty fast after the Black Rabbit. But it's still a little long, isn't it? I mean, it's not stupid long like it was before. Remember when, like, when Jason got like really kind of in shape and he was doing Black black rabbit and he had the long hair and he was really ripped up. And Amanda was like, it's kind of, it's kind of. Amanda was like, it's kind of like having sex with like a stranger.
And she said with kind of with glee. With some tweaker you give a ride to, we're right home for it. She was a little too excited about last night. We know. A little change of pace never hurts. But we missed you, Shawnee. It was the first time. I know.
What, did you guys get together last night? Yeah, we did Sunday dinner. Oh, man. And it was the first time in a while for me. And it was so great seeing everybody and seeing this guy. Did Carolyn go? The love of my life? No, she was...
It's not working out, Sean. It's not working on. We're making news today, guys. No, no, no, no, no. We are not making news. That's not true. Something came up, and then we had... But we had Danny and Don Dees,
which was raising them. I just heard from Don, yeah, she's great. Willie Speck. Oh, man. The whole crew. Jimmy Hedge. And we saw a sweet... Sweet little maple.
Oh. Oh, Richard and Jenny. And Richard and Jenny. But Jennifer Aniston wasn't there, was she? Oh, you know it, girl. Yo, you know it. She was frying up some, what did we have last night? We had those burgers.
By the way, how about Thoreau had sleeves last night? Yeah, well, it's cold. Yeah, it was a little cold. Jeez, man. He had sleeves, but he had two T-shirts. He had the layered T-shirts. He did. He had a Steve Bannon combo going.
Oh my God, everybody was there You guys were missed You and Scotty Sorly missed Sorly missed Any way you can get a vicious stomach virus And get fired off that play I think about it all the time
You know yesterday was the big big big snowstorm Massive so we had Oh so we canceled We had a cancel rehearsal So I still wanted to run Is this you guys rehearsing out in a park I mean, the gun, no, little excuse, let's take a day off. Yeah, we're doing, it's outside.
It's in the, it's in Central Park outside. No, I said, so it was rehearsal, because you couldn't drive or go anywhere in the streets or whatever. So anyway, so they canceled, and I said this, but I still wanted to run the show, so it's like fresh in my head, you know? So I said, Scotty, there's a performance in the bedroom tonight. It starts at 7 p.m. There's one ticket because there's one chair in the bedroom.
I said you can, there's a bathroom. There's no intermission, but there's a bathroom right next to the chair. And if you want to fall asleep during the performance, there's a bed. Jesus, I'm getting a heart on. Tell me more about it. What a cell. Yeah. What a cell on this play. I mean, Jesus.
How many times does that pitch come out of your mouth? There's a performance in the bedroom tonight. I was going to make a joke, but then, Sean, it occurred to me. You know what would be a great biopic you should do? Because you know a lot about it is the story of Chef Boyardee. Why not? The Chef Boyerdy story. Don't fucking threaten me.
But how does the rehearsal for a one-man show go? What do you mean? It's just him. It's just you're up there and then the director sitting in the middle of the house. Yeah. It's just a couple. Tech is just you and it's just right? It's weird.
But you know, the... Do you light the show with a flashlight? Is that it? Yeah, well, people have to use their phone lights. That's how we get the light. Everybody in the audience. No, they, during the run through the other day, we had our first quote audience,
but it was all like the producers and the people, doing behind the scene stuff. So it was like 20 people, which is a lot of people who have to have been rehearsing by yourself. And so I walked in and I started laughing. I'm like, I can't do this. This is insane.
Oh, God. I all start panicking. Now, I think we talked about this before, but forgive my old man brain. I've forgotten. Do you have some sort of a net, some sort of a fail safe? Like if I go up,
so somebody just off stage? Yeah, well, for previews, which are two weeks, there'll be somebody in the front row on book. Front row. You can't look to the audience for the line.
No, but you can just say line or whatever. Really? And the person in the front row, like, there's going to be a person in front row with a script in their hands. This is correct. When you say a person, you mean Scotty, obviously.
Yeah. Isn't that going to be distracting for the people around this person that this person's snapping script pages? What are you going to do? I'll tell you what you're going to do. You put somebody off-stage in the wings. For the show,
that's something to do when we open. Don't tell them how to do. But they're selling tickets for the preview. That's correct. That's correct. I don't get that. Because they get to see how the sozy just made. It should be a discount and ticket them because Sean has never shit together yet.
What are you at advocacy group? What are you doing? By the way, Sean, quick question. First of all, Sean, obviously Jason, I are thrilled to have you on the show. Do you, are you, shone, is... I'm such a big fan of both. We don't usually have theater types. You're so good.
Do you have any stories that you like to... Shottie, do you, is Scotty offbook? Seriously? Wait, I mean, because I'm running lines with me? I mean, a tiny, not really, I mean a tiny bit. Scotty, come into frame. Scotty, are you off book over? Oh, wait, he's way down there.
Scottie, you off book a little bit? You know that, you love that one line, I say. You know that one line. The one you always say, you nailed it. What is it? Shut up, Scotty. Just shut up. Hey, Scotty, what's the first line of the play?
I don't know. Oh, that's. That's your man, front row. What if the lights come up, I'm like, line. Did you get a deal on him? I told you that thing when I auditioned for David Chase for the Sopranos and I had one line and I got the Silver Cup and George Ann Walker's the casting director.
I go and she goes, I know you're going to meet him, but he wants everybody to say one line. I was like, one line, how am I going to, you know, a bunch of actors out there for it? This is like 2001 or two. Anyway, I go out there. I go into the room David Chase,
Jordanne Watkinson there and I've got this piece paper with the one line and she goes, you ready to start? I go yeah and he's just watching us to get a me
deliver it to her and I just go line and he burst out laughing and I got the job not a comedy but he was I think he was so he was like this motherfucker
was this for sopranos? Sabratos yeah you were on the sopranos? Yeah I know that's a lot of people say wait come on really? I didn't know Can you believe I still have not watched that show?
I haven't either. It's real good. It's real good. It's going to be a hit, I hear. All right, come on, here we go. Jamie, let's get to your guests. I mean, let's get to your guests. I mean, she's probably left or asleep by now.
Here we come. Wait a second. Let me pull up the notes. Here we go. Here we go. Guys. Yes. Today, we have an actor that I met once very briefly and was as knocked out by her charm
and warmth as you would think that you would be. She's one of our biggest stars, an incredibly successful producer. She kills it in both comedy and drama, big films, and small. She has box office success as well as critical praise. Her nominations are numerous, including two for an Academy Award. She knows how to hold her breath for five minutes. She's a trained pickpocket in Will. She plays ice hockey competitively.
She's at the top of the mountain folks, but is cleared an hour for a good old smartless chat and giggle. And I couldn't be more grateful to her. Gang, please welcome Ms. Margo Robbie. No. Oh, bang. Hey, Margo. Hi, Margo.
What's going on, Margo? She's a big Rangers fan. I am. I've been seeing here, giggling, listening to you guys. I'm sorry. That was really fun. We tried to keep it tight. That was my favorite part.
Yeah, I love the Rangers. Have you guys seen each other out there at the garden? No. No? I've seen you there. You know, I'm, yeah, I'm incognites. but I'm short for incognito. I have to say, before we keep talking about hockey, which I hope we do, Will, I have to say,
I fucking loved is this thing on. And I, you are so good in it. And I swear to God, as soon as I finished, this is a good. Literally, as soon as I finished watching it, the first thing I said, I was like, give the man the Oscar. Like, you were so unreal in it. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much.
And now, let's have your review on this look, this new look. You in love with them as I am? Honestly, quite the reveal when I whipped off the piece of paper from the screen just there. You look great. All right. Thank you. You look 10 as well. Have you been on holiday?
It's a new bronzer. Right? Jason's new line, he does a lot of men's skin care. This one is water resistant. It's good for all climates. Won't leak on you, won't run. This one is called early June. So it's not too heavy.
It just looks like the summer's started. It's working for you. Margo. So nice to meet. You. I mean, this is so cool. Thank you guys. How exciting.
And I had no idea about the hockey thing. You play hockey? You still play hockey? Do you know what? I don't have, I haven't for a couple of years, but I loved the Mighty Ducks when I was a kid, the movie. And I desperately wanted to play ice hockey, but I'm from a place called the Gold Coast in Australia. And there is no ice. And so there was no way to play ice hockey.
So I ended up playing field hockey all through school. And when I got to America, the first thing I did, I was like, I'm going to play ice hockey. I'm here. I've made it in America. I can finally live out this dream. And so I joined an ice hockey team. Really? And I hadn't really ever ice skated.
Margot, as a Canadian, the nation of Canada is behind you. You are all of a sudden you've reached elite status in Canada. It was so fun. Now, was this before or after the skating training for us? by Tanya. Well before. It would have been very helpful if this came after that. But no, it was well before.
So I hadn't really skated before. I had like here and there like, you know, I don't know, just a few times maybe in my life, but not really. And I kind of, I think I just thought, oh, just run. And there's so much padding that honestly it was fine. But I played in a co-ed team. And there was only one other girl on the team. But you know when you're in all your gear,
you can't really tell that you're a girl. You know, like, I just looked like a very small guy. I had a problem with that one Saturday night. Go ahead. Hey, man, you need to ride. Okay, I want to hear more about that. Yeah, so I just lived like a small dude on the team, so I'd get picked on.
They would check me so hard. But, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's pretty balsy. And then I take off the helmet at the end of the game. They'd be like, oh, shit, sorry, I didn't know you were a girl. But you never got any, you didn't get any, you didn't tune anybody up. You didn't get any fights, right?
fights? No, no, no. I was way smaller than it, bro. Wow, that's cool. All right, so you're out there in Australia and you are, you're enjoying, was it, done a tiny bit of research, was it, was it, was it the infatuation with Harry Potter that got you really excited about movies and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, that, that's what started, where did, where did, where did it, where did it
all start out there? because mom nor dad was part of any of this stuff. No, no one's in the biz in my family. I had never met anyone who'd even so much as walked on a film set. Yeah, you were on a farm, right? Until I was, I was, I spent a lot of time on a farm, but I myself was not on a farm. I was on property, but a lot.
But, no, I don't know. I was just always obsessed with movies. I would just watch them again and again. Like we had a, you know, like most kids from the 90s, like we had a collection of videos, and I'd just watch them to death, and then I'd recreate them, and, like, I was just... And Harry Potter was a big part of them? I was obsessed with the books.
Yeah. So, no, that really didn't bleed into my, like, movie obsession. I was just obsessed with movies and watching them, and, yeah, my mom just used to watch me, like, I'd regurgitate, like, she'd be there making dinner in the kitchen, and I'd just be reenacting something. She kept being, like, how are you, how are you remembering all this? Where is this coming from? Is there one that you would do over and over again?
Is there a particular actor or actress that you were like, oh, God. Goldie Horn, I was big. I loved everything she did. Yeah, likewise. And then there was like, the fifth element was like my favorite film when I was and so I'd try and recreate all those like action sequences. And I was, yeah, I was a bit of a dramatic.
How funny was Chris Tucker in that, yeah. So good. What, then what, what, so then, so you go down to. Melbourne, you get a couple of jobs there such that you feel like, well, maybe this can arm me with the kind of experience and position in the community somewhat that I can go to America and try to parlay that into something bigger, better? Totally. Yeah. I mean, I was on, yes, I was on the Gold Coast, and which ironically now, a lot of movies are shooting on the Gold Coast, but growing up, it felt very far away.
So if you really wanted to do anything, you know, the big. because shows were all in Sydney and Melbourne. I ended up eventually finding my way into an audition for, like, practically a student film and ended up doing that and through that, you know how things are. Like, you do one unpaid thing. It leads to another unpaid thing. And then eventually someone pays you to do it.
And you're about 16, 17, 18? 16, yes. I was in my final year of high school. And then I ended up getting a guest role on a TV show that shot in Melbourne. So that kind of took me to the big smoke. And then once I was in Melbourne, I could quickly parlay like one guest role into another guest role in a TV show with the same casting director. And then while I was in Melbourne, I auditioned for Neighbors, which is a big, Soap Australia. Oh, yeah, the biggest.
Oh, you've heard of it? Of course, yeah, yeah. I'm up on all things, Australia. Except for I will say I'm ignorant enough that I didn't realize that Gold Coast was the name of the actual city. I thought it was just kind of an area, but it's the actual not. I know. It's kind of confusing. And you also say, you say the Gold Coast, not like.
Like in, I don't, you don't live in Melbourne, you live in Sydney, but you live on the Gold Coast, even though that's the name of the city. Oh, wow. Yeah, that's up north, northeast, like, Brisbane? Yeah, exactly. An hour drive from Brisbane, an hour drive from Byron. And where are you today? Where are we finding you today?
I'm in LA. Oh, you are. Okay. We're about to start the junket for Wuthering Heights, which is a film that we've got coming out. Oh, I can't wait for that. We're going to get to that. It's so good guys. I can't wait.
Words I never thought I'd say. No, I know. We'll hold you to that. I mean, I'm excited. But, all right, so what's going on with school at this moment? So you're in your last year high school. Are you thinking about college? Are you thinking about another career that might be more predictable,
something that you can count on more? I didn't really know what I was going to, because it still hadn't occurred to me that I could do acting as a job. job, even though I had started doing these like small unpaid things on the Gold Coast. So about halfway through high school, I started, you know, I did my first like, you know, the thing that I described as like a student film. It's like a independent film that never got distribution. So I don't really know what to call it other than a tiny micro budget film. And so I did two of those. I did, I would do commercials for free and, you know, whatever. And then, uh, the job in Melbourne
kind of timed out at the end of high school. So it turned out pretty great that I got to finish my childhood really. And then, you know, two months later, I got the job on neighbors. And then I've been working professionally ever since. So you thought, no, I don't have time for college. Don't have time to get a backup thing. Well, I actually, to be honest,
I didn't have the money to go to uni anyway. And I kind of thought, this is crazy. Am I really going to go to, you know, the thing is, like, you finish school, you go to university. And I know it's like that in America, too, like go off to college. But I was like, but there's, I don't know that there's something I want study specifically. Am I going to put myself in crazy debt for what? I was like, that's insane.
So I couldn't get my head around that. Yeah, because you were lucky enough to know at a young age exactly what you wanted to do, which is great. But don't most, most kids, I mean, I'm talking to my daughters about this now. It's like you don't, you don't, there's no pressure to like know what your career is going to be, at least in your first two years. Isn't it like the third and fourth year where you have to declare your major? I think it's a bit different in America. I feel like in America, Oh, by the way, all I wanted to do was go to college in America because watching movies, it looked like the funnest thing in the whole world. And it would be like, why?
What do you want to study? I'm like, oh, I don't care about what I would want. I just want to go to college in America. That's exactly why you go. I want to go to a frat fraternity party and drink out of red cups and all that stuff. And so I think I get the impression that for you guys in America, it's like you go to college to have a college experience. And at some point during that experience, you realize,
oh, I really like this class I'm taking. and now I'm going to shift in that direction. It's not really so much like that in Australia. You kind of have to decide in high school what it is that you, so you're like, oh, I want to be a lawyer, or I want to do business or something, and then you pick your degree and then you do that degree. And it's a little shorter as well.
You can even do your full degree in like two and a half years in Australia. You can kind of back it up like that. My experience was like, I feel like I'm just going to go and waste my time doing this when I know that that's not where. I just want to go and start. start life now. And were you doing what your parents wanted you to do, too? Was that part of it?
Who me? Yeah, you. Yeah, a little bit. Tell me your name one more time. You're handsome. Look how handsome this guy. What is he was? He's handsome guy on the single-d-air?
Margo, I remember in college, we used to have parties and we'd, you know, lug the keg up the stairs. Yeah, totally. In this apartment. Totally, and we'd charge $3 a cup when you come in, we'd buy the kegs.
We'd make all this money. And at the end of the, the night, the floor would just be trashed with a beer everywhere in our apartment. And at that age, you just kind of don't care. No, that's the dream. That's all I wanted. Do you know what? Part of me was, you know, part of me was like, oh, no, I started acting like I said, other neighbors, whatever. And I was like, oh, I haven't gone to university. And I guess I'm never going to at this point. Does that mean I'm, am I dumb? And I remember, I remember asking my sister. I look in the mirror and say that to makes up every day.
I almost wanted to check that this didn't mean I wasn't, you know, it didn't mean I wasn't smart. My sister was, you know, we're very, very, very different people. And so she was studying to be an accountant in university, something I never would have done. But I remember saying, I was like, hey, can I do one of your assignments, one of your uni assignments? Because I just need to check that I,
that acting is not making me dumb. And I did it. And by the way, like numbers and accounting is not my first. forte at all. And I got like an A-minus. And I was like, okay, cool. And then I felt good after that. I was like, I'm good.
I can do it. I know I can do it if I need to. Because of life experience. Well, I mean, I studied. It was all about, you know, cognitive dissonance and some boring shit. Yeah. But yeah. We'll be right back.
And now back to the show. All right. So you get to Hollywood. You got, well, it's not Hollywood first, right? No. So I was on Neighbors for three years, which is a pretty intense. and very, very fun and amazing training sort of thing as a young actor. Yeah, and so I did that for three years.
And then when my contract finished, I started about six months into that job on Neighbors. I'm looking around, you've got a cast of, say, 30 people aging from eight years old to 80 years old. And it's, you know, I looked around and I was like, okay, so some people are life is here. Some people have, you know, just made a life just from acting. And I'd ask the cast members, I was like, so you don't have any side jobs, you don't have a second job that you go do? And they're like, no, just this. And I was like, wow, okay, so you can make enough money doing this that you can like pay for a house and put your kids through school. And they're like, yeah.
And I was like, oh, excellent, great. I'm going to do this then. So I'm going to be an actor then. Great. And then I was looking at some of the younger cast members who would. So there was kind of three choices or neighbors. Either one, you can't keep up. You get fired.
And it's like a revolving door. So, like, you need to be able to keep up. Number two, you are great and you stay and you can be on there for like 20, 30 years. You know, it's a long-running. So, or option three, you do it for a little bit and then you make the jump to America and you try your luck in America. So I knew that I wanted to be in Hollywood and do like American films. Margo, just to be clear, there have been a lot of members, cast members over the years from neighbors who have done that and gone to America and done great things, right? Yeah, and home in a way.
So like the two main so neighbors and home and. in a way. So it's like Kylie Minogue was on Neighbors and Chris Hemsworth was on Home and Away. Wow. Wow. Wow. Yeah. That's wow. All right. So when you, then when you get to Hollywood, is there is there a safety net? Do you come with a bag of money? Do you have an agent ready? There's an Aussie. There's an Aussie mafia ready made for you. Yes. It, uh, yeah, it's, no, like truly, it's like being on Ramsey Street, which is like the street in the show. It was like just being on Ramsey Street again, but in America. So who's taking care of you? You, well, you're your fellow Aussies that have been on soaps as well
and you sleep on their couches and everyone like shares info of like okay because by the way when I moved here it was 16 years ago so I was 20 I moved five days after I finished on neighbors I was quite keen to get here and yeah there was no Uber there was no like it was a different time there was pilot season you had to learn how to drive on the other side of the road well not just that that wouldn't have been a problem it was getting a car you can't actually rent a car to you're 21 and I was still 20 and so I asked the Aussie you know like our Aussie mafia was like you know what do I do if I need to get a car to get around to these auditions
and they're like okay I know a guy and so you'd go to this the guy and he would rent you a car kind of off the books or whatever and then you drive around to your auditions all that Russell Crowe's got a little side gig out and see me valley well I ended up crashing that car on the way and this was not a guy that you you know I didn't get the impressions as a guy that you messed with, but I crashed his car, and I was really scared to tell him. Anyways, he took the car off me, obviously. And then I still needed a car to get around to auditions,
and I went back to the Aussies, and I was like, what do you do when you piss off that guy? Like, is there another guy that you can rent a car from? And they're like, yes, he's called the dodgy Romanian. And I was like, okay. And I rented a car from the dodgy Romanian, as he was called. And it was like this gold-colored, oh, God, I haven't thought about this in you.
It was like this gold color, not a Lincoln, but like it looked like, it was like a boxy color like from the 80s. A big one. And this guy was like very few words, very, you know, like here's the keys, give me the cash. We're not going to chit chat. Just one thing. We don't have an offensive Romanian accent at you? No, thank God. It was like, don't open the trunk ever.
No, come on, really? I am not joking. Because I just don't open the trunk. And I was petrified. And I, no, I desperately. wanted to make it in Hollywood. I'm like, I'm not going on little side quest here to open this trunk and get caught up in whatever is happening here. I am never going to open this trunk. And anyways, I ended up again crashing in this car. I was... What's your battle with you?
You know what? I was always like doing my makeup and changing on the way to auditions and stuff and not paying... It was, yeah, it was a bit of a chaotic time. Anyways, I crashed in this car and I was panicking. I was like, holy shit. What do I do? There's no... You don't even call in. insurance. You got to call the dodgy Romanian and tell him that I've just crashed his car and he didn't kill me, I suppose. And so I called him and he's like, where are you? And I was like, I gave him the address. I was
somewhere in Venice, I think, and it was like nighttime and he was like, I'm coming to you. And I was like, oh God, no. And he rocked up with an associate and they got out of the car and they go to the trunk. He looked at the damage and he was like, okay. And I was like waiting to, I don't know, be executed. And he was like,
did you open the trunk? And I was like, No, never. Like, I literally never. How dare you? And he goes, okay. And he just took the keys, and he drove away. No way. And I never saw him again.
I never got a bill for the damage to the car. Nothing. Truly. Oh, my God. Just went to into thin air. And I still, to this day, I don't know what was in the trunk. Yeah, what was in there? What was in?
Just some cash, just loose cash. That'd be nice. You can't deposit. Just junk. It might have just been junk in the trunk. Oh, God. Just too close. Oh, no.
Did you have junk in the trunk? Did you get to use the car enough to go to plenty of auditions? Did you get use out of the car before he crashed there? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I had a good couple weeks. So what was, so you come to America, let's say, Margo, what was the thing? What was the first American gig? Pan Am.
Is it Pan Am? Yeah, Pan Am. Remember that series? And that at the time, that was like, it was a TV show about the Pan Am. Oh, that's right. It was just a big, it was a big deal at the time. Good looking show. Yeah.
It was, it was a TV show. I think at the time it was the most someone had spent on a pilot before. Yes. They spent like $10 million on the pilot or something like that. It doesn't seem like it's that long ago. I know. And that also now seems like a small budget for like a pilot. But yeah, it was a big deal and I had a role in that.
So that was my first job. So I then moved to New York because we shot that at Steiner Studios in Brooklyn. So then I was living in New York for a year. And my roommate was Christina Ritchie. No way. No way. Wow. Yeah.
No way. So I've gone from being in Australia, like never having, you know, met a single famous person or seen a movie set or whatever to, yeah, living in the big scene. And then was this your first time in New York? Yes. Oh, my God. And what did you think of that? I suddenly, I couldn't comprehend how much of a city it was.
The thing is where I grew up on the Gold Coast, like I mentioned, but my family's all from like inland, Queensland, like the farms, right? And so I had grown up thinking I was a city kid and I thought the Gold Coast was like, like the big smoke. And they'd always call me a city kid because, you know, I was on the Gold Coast. Then I moved to Melbourne for neighbors, and I was like, whoa, okay, this is a city.
I was like, oh my God, I can't believe I thought I was a city kid. I've never been to a city. Melbourne is a city. This is the craziest thing I've ever seen. And then I got to New York and I was like, okay, I don't even know anymore. This is a different level.
This is a city. Yeah, I loved it. I had the best, best, best time. Oh, my God. So you do panic. And then that sort of runs its course. And then you're sort of left wondering what's going to happen now, or was it just offers flooding in?
No, they didn't pick up the back nine. So we kind of had an inkling that we weren't going to go to a season two. It's my job. And then I started auditioning at that point. I auditioned for Richard Curtis's film About Time, which I ended up getting a small role in. And then I also, like everyone else, I auditioned for the Wolf of Wall Street.
So I sent in a self-tape for that, and I ended up getting that, and that was my first American film. No, wait, wait. So you sent in a self-tape for Wolfram Wall Street. So then how long was that process? Was that maybe two or three auditions before you got to Scorsese and Leo? No. No. I went from the tape to being in the room with Marty and Leo.
Christ. Wow. It was, there was no in-between. I don't know how it happened like that, because everyone I knew was sending in a tape, like everyone. So I never thought Martin Scorsese was going to see the tape. I just was hoping that Ellen Lewis, the casting director, was going to see the tape.
And, you know, I sent it in. I didn't hear back anything until I got the call saying, you're going to read in the room with Marty. How long was that? How long was that gap from the time you said? It was quite a while. Like, I can't remember that. Like you'd forgotten about it almost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, you know, like, I don't know, maybe five weeks or something. I don't know. I get the feeling that maybe I was a bit of a wild card option because I think they had a couple of actresses read in the room with Marty and Leo to do a chemistry read sort of situation. I don't know, maybe I was like the wild card where they're like, I don't know, throw her in.
I have no idea. You get a call from your agent, you're like, guess what? That tape you sent in, you're going to go meet Martin Scorsese. Well, no, they said you're going to go meet with Marty. And I didn't know who Marty was. I was like, Marty. And they're like, Marty is what people call Martin. Romanian.
I was going to say it. Dodge you from Maine. So you're going to go meet with Marty and Leo and you're going to read with Leo for Marty. I mean, did they make you feel comfortable or were you nervous? They did. They did. And they gave me the role in the room as well.
No, that's great. So the whole thing was crazy. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, walk us through that. Is it true that you actually? Is it true that you improvise a slap on Leo? Yes, it is true. It is true. It is true. Thank Christ that worked out.
Because that could have gone a different way for sure. Okay, walk us through that. Okay. Okay, so the way that day went, I walk in, I walk in. First I go to Ellen Lewis's office to, like, have a quick pre-chat with her. The great Ellen Lewis. And she takes one look at what I'm wearing. And she was like, no, no, no, no, no.
Like, she was like, you're going to go back downstairs. I think I was wearing, like, you know, my, like, boots and, like, jeans and like a, I don't know, long sleeve shirt or something. And she was like, absolutely not. You're going to go downstairs. You're going to walk that way. And you're going to walk into a place called Soho. There's lots of shops. and you're going to find a tight dress and the highest heels you can find,
and then you're going to come back. And I was like, okay. And so I went and did that, and I came back in a new outfit. And then I, you know, went to the, you know, the audition room thing. And Marty and Leo were in there. And it was quite surreal. And we started doing the first scene. And I just, you know, I'd been on a soap where you have to,
you do like 60 pages a day and you have to be word perfect. Because it's multi-cams, they're switching. They're essentially editing as you do the scene. You are word perfect. So I start doing the scene. And it was all right and whatever. But Leo was like throwing in adlids and improvising. And I'd never ever improvised before.
I'd never seen another actor improvised before. So I was a bit thrown. And I was like, well, that's not in the script. Wait, what's he doing? Okay. And I was like, oh my gosh. He doesn't know his lines. He's like, Leo doesn't learn.
I was like, wow, he's improvving. Okay, shit. And so I thought. I didn't do very good in that scene, I think, because I was playing catch-up a little bit. And I thought, oh, God, I'm getting thrown out of this room in, like, 30 seconds. Like, I've got 30 seconds to make an impression because we are like, this is not impressive so far. And so I was like, okay, forget the lines, just go off script. And just, I just thought, I'm just going to use, like, every swear word I know.
And so they were like, in action. And I just, like, start a script. Because also, Leo can go, you know, like, if you don't get in there, he'll just keep going. and like he can do the scene without you sort of thing. So it's either like get yourself in there or you're like, you know, he can do. And you're in a Brooklyn accent for this? Yeah, Brooklyn accent, which is actually easier for an Aussie
because we don't do, you know, we don't hit our ars like that. So yeah, and then so I just started like, I jumped in quick. I was like, blah, blah, blah, and start screaming or whatever. And so I was like, okay, great. So we're doing this scene and now there's a bit of energy in the room and it's feeling good. And I was like, okay, great. You know, and then there was the last scene, third scene to do,
which ends in a line of now get over, here and kiss me and then it's the end of the scene. And so we end up, you know, I was, I think, feeling a little buzz that I did well in the second scene. So by, I was, you know, a little more bullshit in this third scene. And we get to the end and it's like, okay, now get over here and kiss me. And I thought to myself, wow, I could kiss Leonardo DiCaprio right now. Like, that would be so cool.
I could tell all my girlfriends back home that that happened. That would be like a life experience. And I was like walking towards him slowly having this thought of like, maybe I just do it. like, fuck it. And then I got close and I was like, nah, this character wouldn't do that. And I just went whack and slapped him instead. And it was like, dead silent.
Like, you could hear a pin drop. And I was like, oh, my God, what have I just done? I'm going to get arrested. I think that's, you know, battery or like assault of some kind. Like, can I be sued? Do I go to jail for this? And then he and Marty just burst out laughing. And they were like, like, that's great.
That was amazing. And then they said, you've got the job right there. And they said, that again, let's do the scene again, do more improv, do that again. And anyway, so we workshopped the scenes for a little bit. And then I, you know, said, thank you. And I walked out of the room. And I got in the elevator and I, like, took my heels off.
And I, like, did that, like, little silent jig dance to yourself. Like, oh, my gosh, that was so fun. I can't believe that just happened. And just as the elevator doors were about to close, Ellen Lewis was like, wait, come back into the room for one second. I was like, oh, okay. And I walked back in, my heels still in my hands. And they were standing there, like, just smiling.
And I was like, what's up? And they were like, and Marty just, oh, Marty just held out his hands like this and guys would like to offer you the role. And then gave me the biggest hug. Oh, that's amazing. What a dream. So incredible.
And yeah. That's amazing. Did they ever make the movie? Yeah. Did they end up making the movie, Sean wants to know? Yeah. Yeah, they got that one off the ground. Well, now, okay, so that was that amazing story.
Thank you for sharing that. Yeah, that was really cool. The film is stunning. Your work in it is stunning. It was so well received. Did things, I mean, a massive change for you in your life once that comes out. Was that a comfortable thing? I mean, something you've been working for for a long time.
This was a bigger step than you probably imagined happening. Were you able to kind of like step up to it and hit it? in stride or was it a bit of an adjustment? Well, you know how it goes. It's like you make a movie and then it doesn't come out for a year. So your life kind of goes on for a year. And it didn't, it didn't occur to me that it, I would, do you know what? I just didn't know I was going to be in the movie as much as I ended up being in it.
I thought, because the set was so crazy and so much improvisation and so much like every day. It was like, we were like writing scenes the night before. Like my whole end sequence in that movie, we wrote like the night before in a room at like 3 a.m. We were like, it was meant to be just a scene where I'm. My character comes in and says, I want a divorce and she put some papers down. That's kind of it. And then we ended up kind of being like, oh, we need something more. And we workshop this whole thing, that whole sequence.
So by the nature of the filming process, I thought, you know, there's a lot of experimenting going on, a lot of improv going on. Like, I'm sure most of this isn't going to make the cut. So I thought, I wonder how much I'll be in this movie. And I didn't see it until the night before the premiere. So I had no idea. Oh, no way. Yeah.
And then so I didn't really prepare for it. And I thought, oh, I'll be like a, you know, blink and you'll miss me sort of thing. like I'll be in and out. Like I just didn't think anyone was going to pay attention to me in that movie at all. So I wasn't, I wasn't really, I wasn't really, yeah, I mean,
you got Jonah Hill doing like the most incredible stuff. Everyone, like the cameos are endless. Like every day you'd come into work and people would be like Matthew McConaughey's the other day or like, you know, whatever. So,
so, so, yeah, it just felt like I was one, one blip amongst a big canvas of, of, you know, chaos. And so I,
yeah, I didn't really brace myself for how, how things would change after that. And I'd already done a bunch of jobs in between. Sure. You know, because I had a year. So, yeah, I don't know. Life got weird pretty quickly.
Yeah, but then you go and you see it and you're like, wow. Yeah. Well, no, really, I was thinking, I was like, oh, shit, my family is about to see this. Oh, no. I organized a friends and family screening and I, like, sat down. And the credit started and I suddenly was like, oh, my God, I'm like naked and I'm fully naked and they're all about to see it. And, I mean, there's scenes where we're, like, having sex on a bed of cash. Like, my brother is right next to me.
Like, oh, no. I was like, this is going to be the most uncomfortable thing ever. I never forget, at the end of that screening, I think my family were all a little bit stunned and, like, didn't know what to say, but felt like they should say, congrats or something. And my older brother, he was quite a blokey bloke, you know, quite an noisy bloke. he was just like,
uh, uh, couldn't find the words. And I was like, you know what? We don't have to talk for a while. And he goes, great.
And just like kind of gave me a hit on the back and then walked out. We didn't talk for like months after that. And then when we did, we never mentioned it again. We're like, let's never talk about that. Oh my God.
All right. How soon after that did you get pulled into the DC universe with Harley Quinn? Gosh, that must have been. Oh my gosh, that's right, Harley Quinn. Okay, so Wolf of Wall Street,
2012. You did the movie before that, you did the movie with, what's that great one you did with Will Smith? Focus. Oh, I love that movie. Yeah, it's so fun, isn't it? It's a great movie. You're so good in that movie.
Oh, thank you. That was so fun. Yeah, it must have been right after, it must have been after Focus, because Will and I had already done that movie, and then we worked together again in the first suicide scoredolls. And then where was Itania in all this? Itonia was after that.
After Harlequin? 2017 is when I Tonya either we filmed it or it came out in 2017. I love it. Yeah, that movie is so great. Your performances. I mean, everybody's so sick of talking about the one scene where they just hold on you in the mirror. No, I loved, because again, that was like an in-the-moment thing where, I don't know,
we'll set up and. Craig Gillespie, right? Yeah, Craig, who's the best, also in Ozzy. But yeah, I was kind of like, I was like, let me try something for a second. It might be lame, but let me try it. Oh my God, it was so powerful. That was incredible. And then afterwards, and I was like,
was that too weird? And he was like kind of like really still and he's never still. He's like, he is fast. Like you think, I thought shooting neighbors, he is fast. Anyways, and he was like very still and he was like, that was something. And I was like, okay, cool. Do you me to do? And he's like, don't do anything else.
Let's move on. And I was like, wow. What a great feeling. That's the best. It's the best. You know, that feeling where you're like, oh, something electric just happened. Something. I don't know, maybe it's nothing,
but maybe it ends up being a thing that cool guys bring up on a podcast years from now. So, yeah, at what point... So wait for those cool guys, I guess. Yeah, where are they? When do they join me? And we will be right back. And back to the show.
At what point did you start thinking, God, I would love to parlay some of this, you know, great access and position in the community into producing as well because you're such an accomplished producer. Your company, Lucky Chad. Thank you.
Well, I told you was the first thing that we produced, well, it was actually the second movie we produced, but the first one that came out. So it was kind of kicked things off really nicely. We started talking about the production company in 2013, so the year after Waffle Wall Street. Okay. So after Wufel Wall Street, before it had come out,
I went off to Belgium to shoot this movie called Sweet Frances, which I've actually never seen. and I met my two producer partners, one of whom I'm now married to. So Josie and Tom was second and third AD on that job, and we all became friends on that job. Yeah, Wolf Wall Street wasn't out yet, so that must have been 20. Anyways, whatever, very early on. And that's when we talked about starting a production company,
and we started the company the following year. And, yeah, so it's, yeah, we've had it for like 11 years now. I love that you work with your husband. I just think that's great. My wife and I are working together. a bit now and it's just it's just so i just love it it's oh you love it okay sorry i didn't know which way you're going to go with that yeah and the look on your face you got kind of lost a little now i if i i'd love to get my spouse to play golf too uh you you're you're tom can swing a golf club he has
tried to make me play golf so many times no don't bother i'm going to play with them he's he and are going to become big big golf buddies willie he's uh he's he's he's coming on up oh is that right yeah yeah Okay, oh good. Tom on the board. Are you all golfers together? Are you all going to be golf together? Yeah, yeah, we play at it. Yeah, I love it.
Yeah, I mean, he's obsessed with golf. Like, I feel like every dude I know turned 30 and suddenly overnight was obsessed with golf. Like, I was like, I've never heard any of you talk about golf. Yeah. And they all seem to hate it and themselves so much, but want to do it all the time. It's such a weird. It seems to be a very toxic relationship. It is.
It is just incredibly challenging. thing that is hard to ignore. It perplexes me. It really does it. It really perplexes me. And I'm also like, you can love this thing without me. Like go, this can be a thing that I don't need to play golf. I'm going to set you up with my wife. It seems nice. That is so, yeah,
yeah, Amanda needs to hear that. Let's clip that for Amanda. I'm speaking of will you clip that for Amanda? Thank you. Margo, speaking of golf, I just had lunch two weeks ago, three weeks ago.
On a golf, of course, with a non-crice. Oh, no way. Yeah, who is the real-life CEO of Mattel. This real-life CEO of Mattel. And we were talking about you, and we were talking about Barbie, of course. And I'm like, how did that count? And he's like, he told me, because he's such a great guy.
He's like, this is the pitch. Magro-Rabi, Barbie, that was the pitch. What's that got to do with golf? Really? No, because we were having lunch on the golf course. What golf course? Will? Which golf course was?
I had. Do you remember that? When you called me, I was like, I'm going to come. I was about to say, do you want me to start rattling them off? I hate that I know them all, but. Because that's where he wanted to have lunch. Jason, why are you getting bogged down in the detail? I need to understand. How does Sean Hayes end up at Hillcrest? Oh, I got
a pass. What is with the look on your face? Why are you so mad at him? Who has lunch at Hillcrest unless you're making the time? Are you not allowed at Hillcrest? No, a friend of ours set us up as just to have lunch. You guys would have a good time, so we had a good time, and I talked to me. And he's Look at his face.
Oh, yeah. People can only hear this. You can't see Jason's face right now. It is. Yeah, she's wonderful. It's gorgeous there. Yeah, it's hard to get out there. And you just thought you just have your sandwich out there, I guess.
He's so mad. Anyway, Enon spoke very highly of you. He's such a good guy. And when he told me, the pitch was just you and Barbie. That's where it started. And then everything else just kind of snowballed from there, which is incredible. So we're going to fly over Quentin.
Tarantino and Once Upon a Time in Hollywood and we're going to go right to Barbie. No. Right to Barbie. No, wait. We don't have to talk about Barbie. I just thought, what a coincidence you're here and I had lunch with Inan and it was very... No, he made the golf match and that's fair enough. That's a very good...
We will allow. Once Upon a Time in Hollywood. Once Upon a Time in Hollywood What a film. What a film. What a film. Now, is being on a set with Quentin as exciting as it seems? Yes. Yes, yes, yes. It is everything.
I'm a huge Tarantino fan. and it is, so I've read, like, you know, all the folklore around making a movie with Quentin. Like, he doesn't allow our phones on set and da-da-da-da-da-da. It's all true, and it's everything you'd want it to be and more. It was just the best. That's an awesome, awesome, awesome film. I so love that.
I still can't believe. You're like, remember when that first, I think was it Cannes where it first was shown? Yeah. And he made some declaration to the press in like a really cool way saying, Listen, I know some directors say, you know, please watch the spoilers when you write these reviews and everything, but he like made this like real, like, but I'm serious.
Please try not to reveal the ending to everyone, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I remember reading that and going, okay, this is never going to last. Somebody is going to spread. But I remember that I made it to watching the movie, which was months later, without ever hearing what the ending was about, and was so excited by the reveal of what that ending was
and fucking love the way that thing already. wraps up. I just, what a film. I know. Isn't that amazing that no one spoiled that? Yeah, I couldn't do. That was like a separate part of the script that only a few of us were allowed to even have. And so like the crew didn't have it. Like it was kept so under lock and key because you really wanted to preserve that. And it's so impactful when you get to the end of the movie and you're like,
holy shit, Sharon's live. Wait, this means Sharon Tate lives. Like this is such a great alternate universe. but I you know knowing how secret he wanted everything to be I I never breathed a word of how it ended and at can I brought my mom to watch the movie and I asked her afterwards you know we're all clapping and I was like what did you think and she she goes honestly I have been dreading watching this movie because I did not want to see my daughter be killed in the way in that way like in a no Tarantino movies are violent and like she's like I know and I didn't want to you know burst your bubble because you know, clue was so excited about this, but like, I've been dreading it. And she was like, I didn't know. Anyway, so Quentin was looking at me.
He's like, he's like, did your mom like the movie? And I was like, oh, she was upset because she thought she was about to see me die. And he's like, you didn't tell your mom, you don't die? And I was like, no, you told me not to tell anyone the ending of this movie. I didn't tell anyone. He was like, well, at least tell your mom. And I was like, I didn't tell my husband. I didn't tell my mom.
I didn't tell anyone how this movie ended. So, yeah, we were all in keeping it, keeping it secret. All right. All right. So, all right. the behemoth of Barbie, it comes into your world in sort of a typical way, like kind of through the regular sort of channels, or is it something that you pursued? No, not really.
I mean, no, we pursued it. Like, as the company, as Lucky Chap, we went after it. We knew that the agreement over, you know, it was set up already over at Sony. There had been versions of it, et cetera, et cetera. And then their time was kind of up. Deadline Hollywood, don't worry, he knows the deal of it. Hey, yeah, Amy Schumer, you know, blah, blah, blah. Yeah.
There was a tournament for a while. Sure. He knows. He knows the deal. A bunch of money against it. And then... Exactly.
But there was, you know, like, they had to re-up the deal sort of thing. And so that was the opportunity to get in there and say, can we take it? And so we kind of made our pitch to Enon, Sean's friend. So we made the pitch to him. We're like, let Lucky Chap produce this. Let us have this.
We'll set it up at Warner Brothers. So there's no chain of titles issue with whatever they've previously developed. This is before Greta and Noah? Yeah. Before Greta and Noah, so it was just us. So then your take then was, sorry to interrupt, but your take, because the reason it's sort of, it is relevant and interesting that it had this life beforehand was that obviously the version at Sony with Amy would be wildly different than what you guys were doing.
Because think about it, like, that's what the, Mattel, you know, they've got all this great, you know, IP, they're just like games or in this, you know, an action figure. And it's like, how do you come up with a movie about that? You have to have a take. Like, what's the angle going to be? What's it going to be about? And with Barbie, it's so loaded to like, you can have a cultural reference to it, some sort of societal comment, all this stuff.
So what was your take? So this is before you had the writer and the director. Did you have a clear idea about what you wanted to say with this? and then that informed where you looked for a writer and a director? To be honest, the first hurdle was getting them to let us have it. Right. And so really those first conversations were about making sure Enon and Mattel knew that we would protect the brand and take care of it, but also do something meaningful with it.
And we were quite honest in that first meeting of like, if we're doing a Barbie movie, we're going to be saying something and it has to be culturally relevant. And this has to be elevated and cinematic. and all the things. Like it's, but do understand, like, we're going to be making comments with the movie sort of thing. So obviously we'll do that with someone who's very smart. Like, I did pitch Greta in the meeting.
I was like, you know, like a Greta Girlwig. Yeah, so smart. Who I had spoken to previously about other films and stuff. And she, I think at the time was filming little women, but she had done Lady Bird. Anyways. And so, yeah, so first, step one really was just like letting them know that we would, we understood how important this property is to them that we would be good partners to them
and then also like, yeah, then it was setting it up the studio and then it was going after Greta and being like, do you want to do a Barbie movie? And then it was about what her take was really. It was never me being like, I have a take, do you want to do this? It was like, I trust you to have something.
I bet you have something to say, what would you want to say with a Barbie movie with me? And then it kind of went from there. And her and Noah, where their writing process is fascinating, but they don't really plot out. They don't outline a whole thing and then send in an outline,
you know what you're going to get. They don't really know how it's going to end. They write as they go. They write themselves in corners. They write themselves out of corners. So getting the studio and Mattel to sign off on the movie and get them paid to commence because then it was COVID too, and I was like, they need to be writing right now.
And they were like, well, what's the movie? Yeah. And everyone's feeling very protective over this thing and want to know what it is and what they're paying for and all that kind of stuff. Yeah, it was kind of, yeah, I think it was probably the best bit of producing
we ever did was getting, getting that whole, all those deals, treatment deals, you know, no approval over the script, but approval over the treatment, like all this kind of stuff so that they... You got to convince a lot of people that sort of like, just trust us,
just trust us. It was completely just trust us and also leave them alone. Like you cannot. They're not going to get on the phone with you and tell that they're not going to pitch you. Like, we have to leave them It says a lot about Mattel and Warner Brothers for taking that risk and, like, that's a lot of courage.
It's so great that it worked out so well for them. I've been huge. I mean, I asked the dumb questions if you haven't picked up on that yet. So will there be a sequel? Well, there could be. Because, I mean, why wouldn't there be? But Greta's been, I mean, I'm open. There's no plans at the moment, but I'm open to it.
I'm open to anything with Greta, to be honest. But she's been doing Narnia for ages. I can't wait for that. Cool. Yeah, she's been like really intensely into it. Do you love them too? Have you read, do you? Have you ever read a book series called The Magicians?
It's like this like grown up dark Narnia version of Narnia. No, but I will. It's so good. Yeah. Tell us Sean what channel it's on and he'll watch it for fun. Books, they're books. Wait, the magicians. Oh, wow.
Is it the same tone as the Narnia books and stuff? Well, it just, it's like, I love fantasy books. I read a lot of fantasy, and it's a really good. Oh, good. Well, then check them out. I mean, it's just, but it's very much seeped in like Narni allure, which I, which I... Why don't you, why isn't your production company option those books?
Well, actually, if I'm going to option anything, I read a lot of, like I said, a lot of fantasy, but I read a lot of romantasy books as well. So, I think since our brand is very, like, female-focused, there's some other romanticcy books that I'd rather go after. Well, that's getting us right. Right to Wuthering Heights. Yeah. Yeah.
With the divine Jacob Allorty. What a nice guy. Just met him the other day. What a really, really good. By the way, sidebar, we just had Charlie XX on. And she did the music for it. She did a whole album. She did an entire album.
Yeah. Her whole album is called Warwick Heights. Yeah. And another collaboration with you and Emerald Fennell. Yeah. Third film together. So we produced Promising Young Woman, then Solt. and now this is her third film and our third film together.
She's only been in the States for 16 years. I know. Look at all of this. It's amazing. It's amazing. It's amazing. So Wuthering Heights, you're a big softy with the romance stuff. Was this, did this come out?
It's the ultimate romance. It's the ultimate, yeah. It's much like your relationship with golf. It's like you just can't, you can't help it even though it's destroying you on some level. Thank you for putting it in a context that we can understand. Thank you. I'm currently in a divorce with golf right now. I'm working.
I'm going to be dedicated to my life right now. But okay, so now you've seen the film. Many times, yes. Do you cry every time? Every time. I have never watched it and not cried. I love you. And I, like, it's, yeah, it's so good.
I mean, it's just, I'm so excited that everyone's about to see it because it's incredible. It's coming out on Valentine's Day, right? Perfect Valentine's, Galentine's plan. Yeah, if you don't have plans. Friday, February 13th. It did come out three days ago. Yeah, February 16th today, you guys.
It's out now. It's February 16th today? Okay, guys, if you haven't seen it yet, I apologize. Okay, so does that mean, is it the Monday? Is it the public holiday today? Okay, you've got time. Go to the movies right now. Even as I slap this laptop down, I'm going. Yes, it's President's Day weekend.
It's President's Day. It's Valentine's. It's a big weekend. Go out see it today. Today, go see it. It's just an incredible film. Like, it really, really is. And it's so moving and evocative and provocative and provocative at times.
But it's, I really think it's going to make people feel. And then what about, did you, because it's chemistry with an actor is so vital. especially I would imagine if you're doing some sort of a romantic film with someone. Did you do some research about, like did you call around with people that, or did you know Jacob from Saltburn? So yeah, I knew him in a kind of like a producer-actor dynamic from Saltburn and always thought he was so lovely and so talented. I mean, I was the very, when I read Saltburn, it's the first thing I said.
I was like, Jacob Allorty should play Felix. I was such a fan of his work from Euphoria. back then. So then you knew you two would get along. Well, we're also from, he's from Brisbane and I'm from the Gold Coast. So we're from like an hour away from each other. We're both Queenslanders. So I don't know.
I had a feeling I was like, we're both Queenslanders. We'll be best names. It'll be great. Yeah. He's also, he's just so good. And I think what really helps is we approach our work in a very similar way. And I think that really helped. And I think when it comes to chemistry.
And how is that? Well, we're both very, we're both very, very, very, like, we take it very seriously. We do a lot of prep. We do a lot of work, you know, like, we're both on set with, like, notebooks and writing and notes, and, you know, like, we're, you know. Yeah, so I don't know. And we were kind of, to be honest, I think we were kind of set up for success
because the script was so good. I mean, and Emerald's an Oscar-winning screenplay writer. The script was unbelievable. We had, you know, then the source material has been, you know, adored for almost 200 years. Then you've got Emerald's take of it, and her writing's incredible, and she's plucking out lines and stuff in the book, too.
And then you've got, you know, some of the industry's best designers, cinematographers, production designers, costume design, all that kind of thing. You know, we had all the elements. Where'd you shoot at? We shot in London, and then on the Moors in Yorkshire. So that's so beautiful. And so, yeah, I mean, we kind of had it all there,
and it all came together. and we get along and it was, yeah, it was just great. It was so great. I can't wait. I know. I'm so excited to do that together. I mean, you're so, I'm so taken with you, you seem so charming and warm, as I said, at the beginning. And grounding.
You're just such a pleasure. You're just a farm girl. Yeah. That's all. What knocks you off, what knocks you off balance? When are you not charming? When are you not? Like, what would Tom?
What would Tom tell us is really your kryptonite? Yeah. When I'm hungry. Oh, yeah. You don't, I'm not charming when I'm hungry. And I'm almost always hungry, to be honest. I get angry. Yeah.
He calls me Dragoons sometimes. He's like, he knows, he's like, I need to feed the dragon. Does he cook for you? Yeah, he's an amazing cook. Is he? Yeah, he could be a chef. He's so good. Really?
I want to know how to cook. God damn it. You guys will be golf besties. You can, oh, don't even get me. You think he loves golf. You should start cooking for you, J.B. You should see what he does with the big green egg. He's, oh, my God.
I'll steal him. It's his other mistress. I'll just take him. Yeah, take him. Take him. He'll love it. What's your go-to? What's your go-to meal?
If you're like, honey, I'm really hungry. I fix my favorite thing. You know what it is. What is it? To be honest, he can, he can cook a steak better than any restaurant can. Like his steak, like, it's almost ruined getting a steak. Oh, I don't know what he does, but it's magic. He does that in the green egg?
He'll do it. Oh, no, I think he does a bit of a, I think he does a little. slash reverse sear in a skillet pan situation for his steaks, but he can do it on the green egg as well. Somebody made me a hamburger once and put an egg on it with blue cheese. I was like, no thanks. No, that's cool. That's cool.
Save it for the book. Marko, yeah, this is Margo's time, Sean. Thank you so much for joining us today. I know you've got a lot of press in front of you. I appreciate all the time. Yeah. And best of luck with the film. We're going to watch it this afternoon.
We're all going to go to Century City. Are you actually? Yeah. We're going to go to Century City this afternoon. Oh, yeah. Oh, yes, of course. It's the 16th today. Yes, go watch it. Go watch it together.
You're our core demographics. So enjoy, tell me with you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So great meeting you. Thank you for doing this. No, thank you. Good luck with the play as well, Sean. Oh, thank you, honey.
Thank you so much. So sweet of you. All right, well, hopefully we'll see you soon. See you soon. Bye, bye, bye. Bye, bye, bye. Bye, bye. Oh, I mean, I need a shower, all the negativity and that's just the chump.
I know. I mean, she is something else, man. I mean, what an angel. I mean, bam, bam, bam, bam, movie, big movie, big movie, big movie, big movie. I mean, she's, and she just got here like five minutes ago. And when she said she was on Pan Am, I felt like that was like five years ago, what was, like 15 years ago?
But if you just look at like, she just so hit the ground running, coming here. You know what I mean? And just doing quality things after quality things, always really good in everything she does. And I think the thing, what's almost impossible to get my head around is, Sean,
you parking at Hillcrest and then you go over to the patio to have lunch? Like what are you indoors? What is going on? How did you get in there? Wait. You got there. Jason will take this to the, for the rest of those days. But wait.
You ended up at Hillcrest Country Club. I can play there, but as a guest. Okay, so why? Is it hard to get in? I'm not, I'm not like, I can't call in and have a fucking lunch date there. I'm not a member. So you have to be a member to have lunch there. So mad.
Was the Mattel guy a member there? His name is Enon. No, a friend of ours was a mutual friend of us. No, not two fucking non-members having a business meeting. Unbelievable. All right, getting back into it. This woman, an incredible act.
incredible producer I think will just be at the tip top of our profession for a very, very long time as she is now. Talented, beautiful, smart, all those things. Oh, you have something you want to say, Sean. Yeah, I do just really quick. Out of all the movies that I would have ever guessed
would make out of all of her movies on her resume still rolling. All of her movies on a resume that would have made over a billion dollars, I would have never guessed it would have been. Bar-bye. Bar-bye. I can't believe this.
Let me explain to you what the buy thing is. Wait, at least go, at least go buy, Tanya. Oh, shit, that's better. I just don't think you can, you can't make up a word for it to fit the buy. You have to actually find a legitimate buy-bye-bye-bye. Bar-bye. Bye-bye. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by,
Bob Armjurf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.